foreign
[Music]
six years have already passed since the
last movie in the Alien series alien
Covenant was released although the
movie's Prometheus and Covenant caused
mixed reactions among viewers the
franchises by no means over as a soft
reboot of the sci-fi classic is already
in the works the Standalone movie with
the working title alien Romulus is
expected for 2024 and although there is
no teaser or trailer yet a lot is
already known about it learn all the
latest details here in this video
alien Romulus will have a distinct
storyline that works independently of
the other movies this means that we'll
not follow the plot of Prometheus
Covenant or the original movies the
creators claimed that they not only want
to provide access to the franchise for
Die Hard fans but also give newcomers a
chance to immerse themselves in the
alien Adventure we will see a group of
young people who on a remote Outpost
come in contact with the famous
facehuggers those beings who lay eggs in
humans to create the dreaded Xenomorphs
whether the story will be limited to the
planet alone is not yet known neither is
it known whether it will stop at just
one movie or if more sequels would be
coming in addition to the new alien film
adaptation a TV series is also being
planned overseen by Fargo producer Noah
Hawley it is quite likely that these
stories will be connected with each
other
the cast of alien Romulus is getting a
lot younger when compared to the old
films the lead role will be played by
Kaylee spainey a 24 year old American
who had her first big role in Pacific
Rim Uprising and was last seen in the TV
series The First Lady also joining the
cast is David Johnson who some of you
may know from the rom-com Rye Lane
meanwhile the cast member Archie Renault
became known with his role in the
Netflix series Shadow and Bone just last
year actor Spike Fern Isabella Merced
and Eileen Wu are rather unknown but
have a shot at making it big in
Hollywood with a role in this franchise
the oldest in the cast so far is actress
Phoebe Waller Bridge whom we will also
see in Indiana Jones in the dial of
Destiny the move to a very young cast is
a new approach for the alien film series
and certainly an exciting experiment
typically one might think that this is
meant to Target more of a younger
audience but since the movie will almost
certainly get an R rating we can't
really believe that
filming on alien Romulus has already
begun so we hope to see a first teaser
or trailer later this year the producer
is again Ridley Scott of course who
already directed the first part and was
the producer of Prometheus and Covenant
however a new name is joining the alien
franchise as a director in order to give
the movie That Special Touch of shock
and horror the director of the Evil Dead
reboot fadee Alvarez has been hired
together with his colleague rodo sidewez
he also wrote the screenplay with this
crew there is hope that the movie won't
be toned down too much a first
impression is given by initial images
from the set where we can see the
dreaded facehuggers thankfully a
theatrical release date has now also
been announced alien Romulus is slated
for release on August 16 2024. we are
absolutely excited
and that was all the latest information
about the new alien movie what do you
think should we give the new cast an
opportunity or is the franchise slowly
becoming stale for you and what is your
favorite movie of the series and why let
us know in the comments
[Music]